[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight as you may have heard
president Trump has fired former deputy
FBI director Andrew McCabe if you
haven't heard welcome back from New
Zealand this is the biggest news story
in America president fired him on a
recommendation from the FBI's career
internal investigators and despite all
the attention this firing is getting as
a practical matter doesn't mean that
much mccabe was set to retire in days
anyway
and contrary to news reports he is not
at risk of losing most of his enormous
federal pension much bigger than the
pension you're not getting but none of
this has stopped the usual hysteria
merchants from predicting the end of the
Republic some of the accused the White
House of obstructing justice it's hard
to see how that works exactly since
McCabe was leaving anyway
others have called the firing an assault
on democracy as if unelected career
bureaucrats found guilty of misconduct
by their own agencies were somehow the
linchpin of representative government
once again had all these dumb people get
jobs on television that's another show
but tonight they're really only two
questions that actually matter here
first did Andrew McCabe do anything
wrong and two if so did it justify his
firing well according to the FBI's
Office of Professional Responsibility
McCabe allowed FBI agents to disclose
sensitive information to the press leak
he then lied to federal investigators
about what he did
that's what the investigation found now
if mccabe really did that losing his
pension ought to be the least of his
worries because lying to the FBI is a
felony try it and find out Martha
Stewart went to prison for that Michael
Flynn had his life destroyed over it
mere mortals are not allowed to lie to
the FBI they wind up in handcuffs when
they do and of course it's a far greater
threat to all of us when FBI officials
lie the FBI is the most powerful
law-enforcement agency in the world
it has near absolute power over you the
power of life and death
yet weirdly nobody on CNN seems bothered
in the slightest by any of this one of
the FBI's top officials caught lying
about an active investigation whatever
no big deal
punishing him is the crime here that's
an odd response if you think about it
would CNN panelist show concern if I
no a local sheriff lied in order to
frame teenagers for crimes he didn't
commit
how about if your local police
department fabricated evidence dishonest
law enforcement is a big deal no matter
who the president is in fact it's the
biggest deal it's the worst abuse of
power and yet for some reason our
designated watchdogs the very people who
are supposed to be protecting us from
this kind of third-world nonsense I
think it's totally fine as long as the
net result is a bad news cycle for Trump
watch this kind of thing that we saw
with respect to Andrew McCabe is the
kind of thing you would expect Putin to
do my problem is the timing and the way
it all worked it just seemed
mean-spirited the point is to tear down
the credibility of all people involved
with anything pertaining to anything
that might look into this president
which leads one to believe that this is
authoritarian behavior there are kids
getting shot in our schools there is a
there's an epidemic of people dying from
overdoses and what is the president
minding this little vindictive small
let's get rid of McKay and let's deny
him his pension so whether you agree or
not with the politics of the people you
just saw those are buffoonish points
here's something it's not the foolish
though over the weekend the former head
of the CIA John Brennan can completely
unglued over McCabe's firing on twitter
twitter being the place where people
like that now go to lose their minds
here's the quote when the full extent of
your venality moral turpitude and
political corruption becomes known
Brennan wrote to the president you will
take your rightful place as a disgraced
demagogue and the dustbin of history
finger smoking as he typed it but here's
the interesting part in response to
Brennan's tweet the one you just heard
former UN Ambassador Samantha power
wrote this quote not a good idea to piss
off John Brennan let that sink in what
the hell does that mean the former head
of the CIA is going to do what exactly
in response no wonder people are afraid
of the deep state this is what it looks
like when it bares its fangs floored us
and we will destroy you in case you're
looking for a real threat to American
democracy and there are some there you
go Alan Dershowitz is an emeritus
professor at Harvard
he joins us tonight professor it seems
like there's only one of two options
either the FBI internal investigators
are corrupt and lying or Andrew McCabe
the former deputy director is corrupt or
lying are there other options and if so
which one of those is right well there's
a very simple way of finding out let
McCabe waive his right of privacy and
demand that the public see the office of
investigation report the Office of
Professional Responsibility report then
we can decide for ourselves
whether or not this was a corrupt
investigation or whether or not in fact
McCabe is guilty of what I have called
testa lying and Comey is guilty of test
the line because remember their
testimony today conflicts McCabe
basically says that he was authorized to
make the leak by the head of the FBI and
the head of the FBI has said under oath
that he has never authorized anybody to
make a leak so this whole issue of testa
lying which was on the front page of the
New York Times just yesterday is front
and center when when the Guardians need
to have guardians when the people who
are supposed to protect us are tests the
lying are testifying falsely for
whatever reason we the public have a
right to know about that well absolutely
and and we want to live in a country
where we can trust our most basic
institutions like law enforcement and
the judiciary so but put this in context
for us well I guess what I don't look I
don't know I have not seen the report
and I'm taking it at face value and
maybe I shouldn't my real point however
is that the allegation is a very serious
one that the deputy director the FBI
might be lying about a current criminal
investigation why are so many others
dismissive of that like it's no big deal
Larry tribe your former colleague at
Harvard for example why because
everybody is so involved in this
partisan conflict that anything that's
done against Trump must be good
according to the partisans on one side
and anything done against Trump must be
bad according to the partisans and the
other side we remember from day one I
said do not appoint a special counsel
have a nonpartisan investigative
Commission like the commission of 9/11
that has incredible trust
and that doesn't have a partisan dog in
this race and they have to be the ones
to make this decision right now the FBI
has lost its credibility the CIA is
losing its credibility congressional
committees are entrusted by either side
it's not too late to convene a
nonpartisan congressional Leo authorized
investigative Commission to look into
whether there was collusion whether the
Russians try to interfere of course they
did but we need to have the evidence and
how to stop them from doing it again
that's what the American public is for
stood in not finger-pointing by both
sides so let's just very quickly take
Trump out of this and if you could just
send a message to your lifelong fellow
liberals who care about civil liberties
about the stakes here what would it be
like to live in a country where the
chief law enforcement agency was
actually corrupt where its leaders were
lying about investigations how might
that affect the Liberals down the road
would you say well I have a message for
both sides you know historically it's
been the Liberals and the Democrats who
haven't trusted the FBI or I've
entrusted the Justice Department and if
said let's make sure that we have
oversight and it's been the Republicans
and the Conservatives who said Oh
anything the FBI says has to be correct
fairly true even J Edgar Hoover now
we've seen it all flip because
partisanship has overcome principle and
my message to both Democrats and
Republicans is get back to principle and
stop this partisanship the American
public is interested and cares about the
truth from a nonpartisan point of view
they're sick and tired of a Republican
truth a Democrat truth a trump truth and
anti-trump truth we need the truth in a
non-partisan way right he wants for
people with guns to be on the level for
sure professor thanks for - that I
appreciate it